Taylor Swift in the news again always
all the time Taylor Swift We can't we
can't get away and we wouldn't want to
why would we want to there's nothing to
get away from We Have It All We Have
Love we have uh you know Intrigue we
have politics dating Travis Kelce the
Super Bowl there sports you know the
Scuttle butt is that she's going to one
day soon endorse President Biden and the
Trump people are figuring out how
to counter that there there and there's
all these lurd conspiracies
about you know what is happening behind
the scenes
and so that's where we are we're we're
all fighting for the
affection of Taylor Swift if
you live in this
country you must be blessed kned if you
will by Taylor
Swift um so then I guess the people that
are the Trump people are going at her
risky
move it's a Gambit I think we give her
the country give her the country why
have an election give her the country
she's gotten to that point now let's
stop pretending this is a
country give it to her how bad can she
do president's not really running it the
guy Biden's not even awake in the
meetings the wife is sitting in the
meetings bringing him back information
so at the end of the day it's like how
bad could Taylor Swift do just give it
to her ask her knock on her door and in
one of her homes and knock on her door
and ask her if she has an interest in
being the president of the United States
and if she says no compel her to be the
president
but how about instead of endorsing Biden
run in his place run run we we don't
care that you don't have any experience
it is of no interest to us we are at the
point very soon where we're gonna just
hand the country over to
someone someone we're just going to give
it to someone we're going to kind of say
we're just going to continue to do what
we do and you can have it if Taylor
Swift is our president the things we
will do the blood that will spill will
be like nothing you've ever seen and
it'll be okay because it'll be the the
most beloved figure on Planet Earth her
social capital right now is so high that
in order to fully take advantage of of H
she must run mhm she must run and
announce it go I I thought about it and
I've decided that the best way to
safeguard our democracy is if I run for
president let her do it if everyone's
just going to talk about this woman
every day all day which is all anyone
does and now I'm doing it because I've
noticed that other people are doing it
what am I going to talk about you want
me to talk about Greek mythology I'm
noticing what's going on around me
what's going on around me is it's a
NeverEnding all day every day discussion
of this
woman and who she likes who she doesn't
like who she thinks is going to be a
good
president and what's her take on the
barbie Oscar snub has she weighed in let
her write a song about Gaza as we bomb
them into Smither Taylor Swift at this
moment in time is the most important
figure
culturally in our country there's nobody
I don't know how this happen it happened
without my involvement or knowledge I'm
just reacting to it and I'm going with
it I'm going with it I'm I'm going with
it I'm asking you to deliver the country
to her give it to her now give it to her
I'm asking you to do it I'm asking you
to do it please let her and Travis Kelce
live in a White House and and and Fire
uh drone strikes at our enemies the
huies and all these other let them do it
let have the CIA come in and say Madame
President and she'll say call me Taylor
and that's her new album her new album's
called call me Taylor and Caris swisher
and the rest of these people whose
brains have been eating uh like
fermented alcohol just you know what I
mean like a fruit rotting their brains
have gone you know why her new album is
called call me Taylor because the CIA
director came in to give her a a
briefing the presidential Daily Briefing
the pdb and you know she just sat there
and she was looking so smart and she
just looked at him and she said call me
Taylor do it give it to her give it to
her I I I will not resist I will not
resist I will cheerlead for her I
because we want to live in North Korea
we want it our undying obsession with
this woman proves that we really want to
live in North Korea let's do it give it
to them give it to them they want the
people out there that you see on the
Chick Filet line that loops around and
around and around it keeps going or the
In-N-Out line it goes back blocks and
blocks and blocks and blocks the people
that are sitting that they have the time
to sit 45 M an hour and a half for food
it's not good it's not that good they
have two hours to sit and wait for
French fries that by the by the time
they get them will will be cold because
they've been sitting
there let give them what they want they
want they want gods and they want
someone to worship they want someone to
worship give them Taylor Swift she can
fall in and out of love with migrants
and the country will react to the
migrant crisis based on who she's in
love with so if she's in love with like
a North African guy you know who came
over it's like hot but if if she dumps
him no migrants then they get kicked the